there's actually a science to life
stories matters so when we hear a good
story as human beings our brain lights
up it illuminates the city of our minds
the neural activity in our brains
increase fivefold
and in addition we basically get given a
drug it's called an empathy drug called
oxytocin that gets released when we hear
really good stories and this combination
of all of these neurons firing at five
times the capacity otherwise we hear a
story plus this really awesome drug
seeping in our brain that makes us feel
good makes us remember things
it makes us care it builds relationships
and that's why storytelling has been
such a fundamental part of being human
since early times and we were sitting
around campfires and chasing woolly
mammoths and trying to rub sticks
together and like figure out how to make
more fire and starting to build tribes
we didn't have written language but the
way that we passed down stories told our
you know next of kin that you know stay
away from the Tigers over there and
donate these berries was through stories
because we saw that it allowed us to
store information and remember and be
captivated in such a different way the
first element of great storytelling is
relatability and if you think back to
Star Wars right what makes Star Wars so
good it isn't necessarily the technology
it isn't just the amazing graphics the
thing that makes Star Wars so good is
that it was based on nostalgia for 1950s
Americana so if you look at the original
Star Wars the spaceships kind of look
like old hot rods from the 50s a lot of
the fashion evokes the 1950s a lot of
the shots evoke the great movies from
1950s Americana and George Lucas was
obsessed with 1950s Americana in this
way so it gave this sense of
relatability that allowed viewers to be
transported to this bizarre crazy
alternate universe where these
weird-looking aliens are getting drunk
and fighting in a space bar and there's
a giant Wookiee who's a dudes best
friend um but they're grounded
all that nostalgia from their life that
they had just had in era where America
in the 1970s was really nostalgic that
1950s Americana and allowed it to click
this actually ties in with the second
key to great storytelling the great
element which is novelty so relatability
isn't very good if it's all boring its
generic it's the same thing that we've
seen over and over again right our
brains also light up when we see
something that's new it was a survival
mechanism from prehistoric times and we
saw something new it was a potential
threat to our lives we had to be on high
alert we had to be wired to pay
attention to it right away
um and so when we see something new our
brains line up that city of our brains
lumen ated it's going like crazy but if
something is too novel it becomes
confusing to our brains um if there's
too much novelty we either get scared or
disinterested and our brain starts to
shut off and go into a survival
mechanism so in storytelling amongst
those first two elements there is this
great Venn diagram between relatability
and novelty and that sweet spot where is
it's relatable enough that we feel
comfortable being transported into that
world but it's novel enough that it
keeps our interest but it doesn't go too
much in either direction and the third
element of great storytelling is tension
this should be pretty obvious right on
the tension is something that carries a
great story along as Aristotle said the
job of a storyteller is to create a gap
between what should be and what is and
then continue to string the reader along
closing that gap between what should be
and what is and reopening it over and
over again until that gap is closed in
the tale ends so in any good story you
need that conflict you need that tension
that's gonna keep the reader or the
viewer on high alert always on the edge
of their edge of their seat teasing them
that this tension gap is going to be
closed before reopening it again again
and again and that's what keeps us
captivated in a story the fourth element
of great storytelling is fluency so a
lot of people in business
in MFA programs I went to a liberal arts
school myself did a ton of writing
workshops think that the key to great
writing is being convoluted using big
words sounding flowery sounding grand
being this person who knows all the
better words than you do but in fact if
you run the best and most popular
writers in history through a reading
level test you'll find that they
actually write at an elementary school
level Ernest Hemingway wrote at a fourth
grade level the same was true of Cormac
McCarthy JK Rowling Stephen King all the
authors that captivated us in so many
ways and sold millions and millions of
books and when I talked to people in
business about how they can tell better
stories this is one of the most
fundamental things that we can do in
business we talk in this weird tribal
speak of office land about leveraging
KPIs to optimize for the next quarter
and really find how we can story scape
our way to a new illuminated landscape
of marketing fluency but that means
nothing to people if you want to
actually connect with people if you want
to tell a story that will bring people
in you have to cut down that barrier to
entry that allows them to get engrossed
to your story you need a right simply
you need to tell simple stories you need
to make the story fluent easy to immerse
yourself into
[Music]